ich fühle aber in diese Dringlichkeit
nicht deswegen kann ich diese Nachfrage
ist die Klimakrise für Sie relevant so
gut verstehen weil ich spüre das bei
ihnen nicht sonst würdet ihr
Verkehrsminister der müsste doch Brummen
an Vorschlägen was wir tun können der
hat ein Riesenproblem und das Problem
geht auch inzwischen oder wird zum
Problem der FDP weil es ein
glaubwürdigkeitsprobe eben für ihre
Partei ich hätte mir so sehr gewünscht
dass sie den Grünen dir auch viel Unsinn
machen so richtig Konkurrenz machen
dass die Bürokratie abbauen in den
Bereich wo wir sagen Windräder schneller
bauen aber was sie gemacht haben ist
dass sie es ausgebremst haben
Windräder reden der Deutschen Bundestag
wird am Freitag das Gesetz dazu
Verfahren hätten wir viel schneller sein
können wir könnten bei all diesen Dingen
schneller sein
Gesetzentwurf aus dem
bundeswirtschafte machen also diese
Unterstellung nach dem Motto da die FDP
sei ja dagegen ist nicht falsch durch
eigenes Regierungshandeln belegt ich bin
für viele Option
[Musik]